Prince Prince Jackson and brother
blanket who now goes by BG we call him
BG nobody's called him blanket name
himself have launched a movie review
channel on YouTube but with cousin Taj
Jackson my 22 year old Prince announced
the new endeavor on Instagram with the
note we know that this is a very rough
first video but we want to take you on
the journey with us as we improve and
develop the show it was just weeks ago
we were getting what was then a rare
glimpse of seventeen-year-old BG at an
Avengers and game screening with his
older brother
those guys are gods to me like I think
the best like director since Christopher
Nolan and I think like they have only
gotten better with each movie which is
so impressive not only are we seeing him
chatting and chowing down on pizza a lot
of Pizza
we're learning that BG is a huge fan of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and saw
endgame three times so far this is gonna
work Steve I know it is cuz I don't know
what I'm gonna do if it doesn't this is
one of the movies that actually it's
better as you watch it and I think I get
fiddy wars I've seen a rather 11 times
down it's still fantastic and it's still
intake but I think you get some more
rich character actions it's like deeper
stuff when you watch this movie I think
so PG largely kept out of the public eye
since his father Michael Jackson's death
in 2009 but his two older siblings
Prince and Paris haven't shied away as
much from the limelight
don't don't let things get to you
[Music]